hi wir sind wieder für euch ZDF heute
live ganz herzlich willkommen bei uns im
Stream wir freuen uns sehr dass ihr
dabei seid der mutige und bewegende
Aufstand junger Frauen in Iran und auch
Menschen er geht um die Welt und er
beschäftigt uns auch heute vor allem die
Analyse und die Frage bringt der Protest
das molaregime zu Fall knickt das Regime
ein darüber sprechen wir heute denn seit
dem Tod der 22-jährigen Massa armini
protestieren in Iran Frauen und Menschen
aller Altersgruppen aller Schichten
aller Geschlechter für
Gleichberechtigung und für ihre
Menschenrechte ihr Ruf Frau Leben
Freiheit
ihr Ziel das habe ich gerade schon
gesagt der Sturz des mularegimes seit
mehr als vier Wochen dauern die Proteste
nun an und die
Menschenrechtsorganisation Amnesty
International sie schätzt die Zahl der
Todesopfer aktuell auf 144 sagt aber
dass die Zahl wohl deutlich höher sei
unter den Opfern sind junge Frauen und
Franziska von thiesenhausen zeigt uns
jetzt einige von ihnen einige Gesichter
des Protestes
dieses Video soll die 17-jährige Nika
chacarami zeigen in Teheran demonstriert
sie gegen das mulla-regime zündet ihr
Kopftuch an
noch in derselben Nacht verschwindet die
junge Frau zehn Tage später wird ihre
Leiche gefunden
auch sie wollte friedlich demonstrieren
Hades nadjaffi 20 Jahre alt aus dem
Norden des Iran bei einer Demo in
karatsch feuern Sicherheitskräfte am 21
September sechs Kugeln auf sie ab sie
stirbt wenige Stunden später
kurz darauf wird auch die 16-jährige
Videobloggerin Sarina Ismail Sade
getötet Sicherheitskräfte sollen mit
Schlagstöcken auf sie eingeprügelt haben
die Behörden sprechen von Selbstmord
[Musik]
Auslöser der Proteste war der Tod von
machsa Amini am 13 September war sie von
der Sittenpolizei festgenommen worden
weil sie ihr Kopftuch nicht
vorschriftsmäßig trug wenig später brach
die 22-Jährige in Polizeigewahrsam
zusammen und starb Grund dafür sollen
schwerste Misshandlungen während der
Haft gewesen sein
seitdem protestieren im Iran und den
sozialen Netzwerken tausende für
Reformen und mehr Freiheit
und genau diesen
Opfern des Protestes wollen wir heute
auch eine Stimme geben und zwar machen
wir das mit Massi Aline judget sie ist
eine der stärksten Stimmen dieses
Protestes sie ist für viele iranische
Frauen eine Ikone ein Vorbild im Kampf
für Gleichberechtigung wir wollen aber
auch sprechen über den möglichen Erfolg
dieser Protestbewegung was kann es
bewirken und was macht auch der Westen
um die Menschen in Iran zu unterstützen
dazu sprechen wir mit Gilda sahibi sie
ist iranische Politikwissenschaftlerin
und auch Journalistin und sie hat vor
wenigen Tagen Außenministerin Anna-Lena
baerbock im Auswärtigen Amt treffen
können da erfahren wir womöglich auch
die Hintergründe wenn ihr natürlich
Fragen an unsere beiden
Gesprächspartnerin habt stellt die gerne
direkt in die Chats wir haben das im
Blick oder einfach per Mail an ZDF
heute-live-adresse kennt ihr at zdf.de
das ganze gern natürlich auch jetzt an
unseren Korrespondenten Jörg Brase in
Teheran vor Ort mit ihm können wir jetzt
zuerst sprechen guten Abend erstmal Jörg
erste Frage an dich was erlebst du in
diesen Tagen vor Ort
also ich bin seit gestern Abend wieder
hier ich war als die Proteste losging ja
auch bereits in Teheran und nachdem ich
hier gestern wieder angekommen bin es
ist klar dass hier große Verunsicherung
herrscht bei den bei den Menschen viele
haben auch Angst mit uns zu sprechen als
Vertreter der ausländischen Medien die
Angst vor Sanktionen des Regimes ist
schon sehr groß aber wenn ich dann
schildern soll wie das Leben hier in
Teheran abläuft da komme ich mir
manchmal vor wie wie ein Spielverderber
weil die Wahrnehmung in Deutschland doch
sehr stark geprägt ist durch diese
Internet Videos die die Proteste zeigen
und auch das harsche Vorgehen der
Sicherheitskräfte gegen die
Demonstrantinnen und Demonstranten das
stimmt auch alles das passiert in der
Tat aber man darf sich jetzt eben nicht
vorstellen dass also das Land hier das
Iran also von Protesten überzogen
sondern Protesten versinkt also wenn man
hier auf die Straße geht tagsüber ist
das ein ganz normales Leben die Leute
gehen zur Arbeit Restaurants sind offen
Banken sind offen die Geschäfte sind
offen und das tägliche Leben geht hier
ganz normal vonstatten und dann abends
kommt es dann vereinzelt hier in Teheran
natürlich aber auch in vielen anderen
Städten im Land zu diesen
Protestaktionen man hat das Gefühl dass
diese Protestbewegung die es gibt und
die auch groß ist und die auch große
Sympathien hat in weiten Teilen der
iranischen Gesellschaft dass diese
Protestbewegung versucht dieses Momentum
aufrecht zu erhalten und ein Level an
Protesten aufrecht zu erhalten um eben
den Druck auf die Regierung auch
weiterhin auszuüben
du hast gerade angesprochen dass eine
Angst zu spüren sei dass Probleme gibt
womöglich für dich mit Menschen vor Ort
zu sprechen ist dir das denn in Teilen
gelungen wenn ja was haben die die
Menschen vor Ort gesagt
also wir hatten durchaus Gelegenheit
natürlich mit mit Menschen zu sprechen
die selbst auch an den Demonstrationen
teilnehmen und das ist ja auch kein kein
neues Phänomen das gerade die jüngere
Generation das vor allem die Frauen hier
in Iran sich auflehnen gegen diesen
Zwang das Kopftuch zu tragen sich
auflehnen gegen die Gängelung durch das
Regime das ist eine Bewegung die ist
schon seit langem gibt und es braucht er
offensichtlich diesen Auslöser diesen
emotionalen Auslöser des Todes von Masse
Amini der das dann an die Oberfläche
brachte und die jetzigen Proteste
auslöste natürlich sagen uns viele dass
sie dass sie unter diesem Regime sich
keine Zukunft vorstellen können hier im
Land viele spielen mit dem Gedanken das
Land zu verlassen ich habe mit einigen
Demonstranten und Demonstranten sprechen
können auch während dieser ersten
Protestwelle die ganz klar sagen also
wir haben hier keine Zukunft mehr
eigentlich wollen wir lieber weg der Mut
ist natürlich zu bewundern dieser jungen
Leute die sich auf die Straße stellen
und sich den Sicherheitskräften
entgegenstellen und diese Wut hat eine
Geschichte und der Mut dieser Menschen
ist wirklich zu bewundern die uns immer
wieder erzählen also das ist so nicht
weitergehen kann dass sie natürlich
Veränderungen wollen die Sympathie in
weiten Teilen der Bevölkerung ist da
viele teilen diese Unzufriedenheit viele
die Mehrheit wahrscheinlich hier im Land
ist unzufrieden mit den wirtschaftlichen
Verhältnissen mit der Politik der
Regierung die schließen sich jetzt
diesen Protesten an von denen ich aber
glaube dass sie jetzt nicht alle
dasselbe Ziel haben also hier
tatsächlich das Regime aus dem Land zu
treiben viele wollen auch dass es halt
Veränderung gibt dass eine bessere
Politik gemacht wird und insofern glaube
ich nicht dass man da jetzt dass man die
Zielsetzung aller dieser Gruppen die im
Moment das Regime kritisieren dass man
die alle generalisieren und über einen
Kamm scheren können
vielen Dank für deine Schilderungen ein
weiterer Punkt in den vergangenen Tagen
die Unruhen und auch der Brand im
iranischen Evin Gefängnis es ist bekannt
dafür dass dort politische Gefangene wie
zum Beispiel Anwälte Künstler
Schriftsteller Studierende sind einfach
viele viele Menschen die sich seit
Jahren gegen das Regime auch auflehnen
dass sie für die Demokratie kämpfen dort
sind und nach diesen gemeldeten
Zusammenstößen und dem Brand sein laut
Behörden acht Menschen ums Leben
gekommen was weißt Du Jörg über den
aktuellen Stand und was weißt Du auch
über den Zusammenhang zu den Protesten
aktuell im Land
also zunächst hieß es ja von Seiten der
Sicherheitsbehörden dass es keinen
Zusammenhang geben würde mit den
aktuellen Protesten und den Vorfällen im
ewigen Gefängnis dass es sich darum
einen Streit zwischen verschiedenen
Gefangenen Gruppen gehandelt habe aber
das wurde dann auch wieder eingefangen
wie überhaupt viele erste Kommentare der
der Staatsführung zu Protesten oder zu
bestimmten Vorfällen dann hinterher
revidiert werden müssen so auch in
diesem Falle hieß es nun aus
Justizkreisen dass das wieder Handlanger
der ausländischen Feinde des Regimes
ihre Finger im Spiel gehabt haben sollen
bei dem was im Evin Gefängnis passiert
ist es gibt wohl jetzt auch
Luftaufnahmen die zeigen dass es doch
sehr große Zerstörungen gegeben hat dass
verschiedene Flügel dieses riesigen
komplexes betroffen sind und betroffen
wurden von den von den Bränden
es heißt dass es über 60 Verletzte gibt
von denen mittlerweile auch vier ihren
Verletzungen erlegen sind man muss also
damit rechnen dass es noch weitere Tote
noch weitere Opfer geben wird und das
ist nicht bei diesen acht bleibt von
denen im Moment die Rede ist
unsere Frage ist ja heute knickt das
molaregime ein und wie reagiert es wir
sehen die Bilder der Brutalität des
Vorgehens wir hören aber auch am Samstag
Präsident drei easy der sagt ich zitiere
bei der Überprüfung der kulturellen
Strukturen ist es unbedingt erforderlich
die Gesetze zu überprüfen zu
überarbeiten zu aktualisieren und
gegebenenfalls auch zu revidieren Jörg
wie passen diese Aussagen zu den Bildern
des brutalen Vorgehens des Regimes sind
das jetzt einfach Worte von tatsächlich
bewusstem Einlenken oder einfach weiter
bewusstes ablenken
also ich denke dass diese Worte auch ein
Zeichen dafür sind oder zeigen dass die
Regierung durchaus unter Druck steht das
Vorgehen der Sicherheitsbehörden findet
hier auch im Land natürlich große Kritik
auch innerhalb der der geistlichen
Kasse oder eben auch von Seiten der
Politik da wird Kritik geübt da wird
darüber gesprochen dass es Veränderungen
geben muss man diskutiert darüber wie
Kritik geäußert und auch kanalisiert
werden kann ich denke dass diese diese
Ankündigung oder easy sein Spiegel sind
ist Drucks der auf der Regierung lastet
man muss einfach sehen dass natürlich
viele verschiedene gesellschaftliche
Gruppen jetzt in diesen in diese Kritik
einstimmen sowohl was die in den
Kopftuchzwang angeht sowohl was die
Rolle der Sittenpolizei angeht aber auch
viele andere Aspekte der aktuellen
iranischen Politik da mischen nun viele
Fraktionen mit die sich da melden es
gibt Diskussionen innerhalb des
iranischen Parlaments was Reformen
angeht also ich denke da ist einiges in
Bewegung und insofern mag mögen reisis
Äußerungen in diese Richtung zu
interpretieren sein allerdings kann man
davon ausgehen dass die Menschen hier im
Lande da erstmal relativ wenig drauf
geben und nicht der Meinung sind dass es
diesen ankündigen auch tatsächlich Taten
folgen zu oft sind sie da schon
enttäuscht worden und insofern glaube
ich ist die Skepsis gegenüber denen
Äußerungen von Präsident raisys hier im
Land im Moment sehr groß
Jörg eine Abschlussfrage noch an Dich
die kommt doch bei Youtube von Userin
Merle rein hat dieser Protest eine
wirkliche Chance also hat er die Kraft
reicht der Mut reicht dieser Aufstand
der iranischen Frauen um das molaregime
tatsächlich zu stürzen du hast den Druck
beschrieben aber was ist die
Einschätzung von dir zu dieser Frage
also die Frage wird mir ja nun sehr oft
gestellt und wir haben über diese Frage
auch mit vielen Expertinnen und Experten
hier im Land gesprochen die durchaus der
Meinung sind dass da jetzt etwas in
Bewegung kommt dass ich auch etwas
verändern wird ob das Regime stürzen
wird da sind sie alle bisher eher
skeptisch und sagen wir glauben eher
daran dass es Reformen gibt die das
Regime anstoßen muss alleine schon
deshalb weil es eben an der Macht
bleiben will und muss deshalb den
Protestierenden Entgegenkommen da ist
denn der tat er das in Bewegung gekommen
und viele sagen mir ja auch dass das ein
durchaus langfristiger Prozess sein kann
der sich jetzt hier entwickelt das ist
dass man jetzt sehen muss wie sich diese
Proteste entwickeln ich hatte ja bereits
gesagt dass dass man versucht den Druck
auf die Regierung aufrecht zu erhalten
dass diese Proteste weitergeführt werden
in verschiedenen Teilen des Landes man
will also nicht dass es abhebt sondern
dass wirklich darüber geredet wird was
man hier verbessern kann was es für
Reformen geben könnte ob es dann zu
einem Umsturz führt im Moment das glaube
ich wirklich nicht also die
Sicherheitsbehörden stehen doch zu
großen zu größten Teilen weiterhin
hinter der Staatsführung und sind
entschlossen diese Proteste zu
unterdrücken und ich sehe jetzt auch
keine Anzeichen dafür dass in großem
Ausmaße die Sicherheitskräfte die
Fronten wechseln also insofern kann ich
mir nicht vorstellen dass wir hier
kurzfristig über einen Regimewechsel
reden aber ich denke und das Teilen auch
diese Einschätzung teilen auch viele mit
denen ich hier im Land Rede sondern eher
das ist ein Prozess ist ein
Veränderungsprozess der jetzt
unumkehrbar angestoßen wurde und auch
Ergebnisse zeigen wird vielleicht nicht
heute aber vielleicht morgen sagt Jörg
Brase live in Teheran hier bei ZDF heute
live herzlichen Dank für deine Zeit und
deine Einschätzung
wir machen natürlich weiter und
analysieren unsere Frage unseren Stream
weiter und das mit ihr sie ist eine wenn
ich sogar die stärkste Stimme des
Protests gegen die Zwangsverschleierung
gegen die Unterdrückung von Frauen in
Iran die Journalistin und Aktivistin
Massi alinaj können uns mal gemeinsam
ihren Instagram Kanal angucken sie hat
da über 8,3 Millionen follow Follower
und sie teilt dann natürlich auch die
Bilder und Geschichten der Frauen des
Protestes bevor wir gleich mit ihr
ausführlicher sprechen können hier sehen
wir einige Bilder die sie teilt die ist
selbst auch oft im Fernsehen zu sehen
sprich dort auch gibt den ganzen Frauen
gibt auch Opfern eine Stimme und teilt
die Geschichten mit mehreren Millionen
Menschen bevor wir mit ihr sprechen
können
zeigt uns jetzt erstmal Verena Garrett
wer genau Masi Aline judget eigentlich
ist und wie lange sie schon kämpft
mit dieser Frau Kontakt aufzunehmen ist
ihm Iran verboten massia linedad
Journalistin und Bekannte Kritikerin des
iran-regimes 2009 verließ sie ihr Land
seit 2019 ist cos Bürgerin für viele
Frauen im Iran ist sie eine Ikone von
den USA aus setzt massier linedad die
sozialen Medien gezielt gegen das
molaregime ein mit der Internetkampagne
wide Wednesdays ermutigt sich Frauen
ihre Kopftücher abzulegen und sich dabei
zu filmen wer das tut riskiert eine
Gefängnisstrafe bis zu zehn Jahren und
doch tun es immer mehr Millionen kommen
ihrem Aufruf nach die Führung in Teheran
will sie mit allen Mitteln zum Schweigen
bringen sehr linejad war früher
parlamentsreporterin kritisierte das zu
hohe Gehalt eines Abgeordneten sang dem
ehemaligen Präsidenten etwas vor für
Frauen ist das verboten
würden sie zuhören wenn ich ein Lied
singe das hat noch nie jemand getan ich
habe eine schöne Stimme
[Musik]
eine Provokation mit Folgen aus dem
Parlament durfte sie nicht mehr
berichten um eine Haft zu vermeiden
gingen sie ins Exil doch selbst in den
USA ist massia linedad nicht sicher
2021 hatte der iranische Geheimdienst
ihrer Entführung geplant seither steht
sie unter Polizeischutz Marcia linedots
Kampf gegen Kopftuchzwang und
Unterdrückung im Iran ist ein
gefährlicher in ihrer alten und in ihrer
neuen Heimat
was das für Sie bedeutet für massiv
alinejad darüber können wir jetzt
persönlich mit ihr sprechen erst mal
schön guten Abend nach New York ganz
herzlichen Dank für Ihre Zeit
vielen Dank danke Frau Aline Schatz wie
würden Sie diese Situation einschätzen
an welchen Punkt stehen die Proteste in
Iran nach den ersten vier Wochen
ja vielen Dank erst einmal dass ich hier
dabei sein darf und ich freue mich
wirklich dass an einem solch
historischen Moment
Korrespondenten gibt in Iran das ist
ganz wichtig das wollen wir wir wollen
dass die internationalen Medien das
merken die Revolution sehen und jetzt
sage ich Ihnen warum ich das eine
Revolution nenne
für Millionen von iranischen Frauen ist
der Kopftuch Zwang tatsächlich die Säule
des der islamischen Revolution vor sechs
Monaten habe ich schon einmal hier in
dieser Sendung den Kopftuchzwang mit dem
Fall der Berliner Mauer verglichen so
wichtig ist das für iranische Frauen und
ich zeige damit dass
man sieht dass das Kopftuch wirklich der
schlimmste Bereich ist und Frauen die
das Kopftuch tragen die senden eine
wichtige Botschaft aus dass sie diese
Diktatur beenden wollen natürlich ist
das ein Marathon das wissen wir es ist
noch ein langer Weg ein harter Weg den
wir noch vor uns haben aber Schulmädchen
Teenager im Iran riskieren ihr Leben
gehen auf die Straße auch wenn schon
über 200 Menschen getötet wurden in
einem Monat aber trotzdem gehen die
Leute noch auf die Straße
absolut ein Mut über den wir gleich auch
weiter sprechen was das mit Ihnen
persönlich vielleicht auch Macht bleiben
wir vielleicht noch mal ganz konkret bei
den Informationen bei den Bildern die
sie ganz aktuell von der Protestbewegung
aus dem Land erreichen was hören sie da
aktuell nach diesen nach diesem ersten
Monat des Widerstands
to be honest um ganz ehrlich zu sein ich
höre von Leuten in den Iran dass sie mit
dem Gewehr bedroht werden die riskieren
ihr Leben im 21 Jahrhundert wir tun
alles innerhalb des Irans sagen sie dass
sie nein sagen wollen gegen so ein
Regime was so brutal ist und jetzt
fordern sie die demokratischen Länder
heraus denn wenn die nicht reagieren
dann kann das Regime im Iran
weitermachen mit dem Töten vielleicht
ein Beispiel es gibt jetzt gerade eine
Petition im Iran das ist nicht ich
sondern tausende von Iranern Iranerinnen
unterschreiben das und sagen jetzt ist
Zeit das demokratische Länder jetzt
auch uns dabei helfen und sich
zusammentun und ihre Botschafter aus
Iran abziehen sie müssen mit
Verhandlungen mit dem Iran aufhören und
das zeigt dass der zweite Schritt auch
sein sollte ich möchte nicht dass sie
sich in die internen politischen
Gegebenheiten im Iran einmischen sollen
sondern die sollen einfach nur sagen
Demokratie sollte jetzt kommen gegen die
Diktatur angehen und deswegen glaube ich
dass Deutschland Frankreich Belgien die
Niederlande und die USA Großbritannien
die müssen sich jetzt zusammentun und
die Demokratie unterstützen man kann
nicht sagen wir unterstützen die
Demokratie und trotzdem noch Millionen
von Dollar in den Iran schicken und den
Killern zur Verfügung stellen die
deutsche Regierung hat Milliarden an
tabatai gegeben eine der
Schlüsselfiguren im Iran und
unterstützen ihn damit also helfen sie
die helfen damit der islamischen
Revolution
und ich glaube dass die Iraner jetzt
gerade hier zugucken und die Geschichte
zeigt dass wenn man nicht stark als
demokratisches Land dann funktioniert es
nicht also klare Forderung von ihnen
Unterstützung aus dem Westen
Unterstützung von Deutschland in diesen
Protestbewegungen vielen Dank dass Sie
das geteilt haben sie sprechen dann ganz
konkret natürlich auch die Maßnahmen die
der Westen gerade unternimmt an dann
bleiben wir doch da vielleicht ganz kurz
bei heute haben die EU-Außenminister in
Luxemburg Sanktionen beschlossen die
sind vorher auch angekündigt worden und
auf dieser Liste stehen elf
verantwortliche vier Organisationen die
Sittenpolizei und auch die cybereinheit
der Revolution Skaten gegen sie alle
wurden jetzt Einreiseverbote verhängt
und das Vermögen in der EU wurde
eingefroren aber reichen diese
Sanktionen die da heute beschlossen
worden sind
das ist wirklich eine gute Frage
natürlich ist das ein wichtiger Schritt
der der unternommen wurde ob wir
brauchen mehr das reicht nicht was
können wir denn damit erreichen wenn die
USA die
revolutionsgarten unter Sanktionen und
auf eine
einreiseverbotsliste tun aber die
gleichen bekommen trotzdem noch ein Visa
und dürfen trotzdem ein Reisen Reich sie
zum Beispiel ich nenne Ihnen den
schlechter die kommen zum Beispiel zur
UN-Generalversammlung das ergibt doch
keinen Sinn die kanadische Regierung hat
auch Sanktionen gemacht aber der
Polizei-Chef bekommt trotzdem ein Visa
für Kanada das sind nur zwei Beispiele
die Iraner trauen diesem Frieden nicht
mehr wir denken die Sanktionen sind ein
guter erster Schritt aber das reicht
nicht wenn
die islamischen Terroristen die werden
sie herausfordern in den USA in
Deutschland und in anderen Ländern
vielleicht ein Beispiel über Jahre
hinweg und das wissen sie auch dass die
der größte Terrorismus in Deutschland
stattgefunden hat
und ich erinnere mich
dass die deutsche Regierung seine
Botschafter abgezogen hat aber das
reicht nicht es gibt US und britische
und deutsche Bürger in Gefängnissen
sitzen und Sie können eingesetzt werden
als Pfand um Druck auf die europäischen
Länder
auszuüben Maduro war zum Beispiel in
Iran putin war im Iran aus Russland
eingereist China
trifft sich mit ramini und die tun sich
zusammen das ist ein Verbund der
Diktaturen und die spielen dann ihre
Kraft aus und machen die Islamische
Republik wieder stark und das sind
tatsächlich Sachen die dürfen wir nicht
mehr erlauben also da noch mal eine
Ausweitung ihrer Forderungen bleiben wir
noch mal bei Ihnen persönlich wenn sie
sie kämpfen ja seit Jahren gegen die
Unterdrückung gegen die
Zwangsverschleierung gegen das gegen die
jobpflicht was macht das mit ihnen jetzt
auf der einen Seite diese jungen
Menschen aus allen Schichten junge
Frauen aber auch aus anderen
gesellschaftlichen Strukturen in Iran zu
sehen die ihr Leben riskieren und auf
der anderen Seite aber auf der einen
Seite den Mut dieser Menschen und auf
der anderen Seite aber auch die Tatsache
dass sie damit diesen Protesten ihr
Leben riskieren
genau das ist es und vielleicht können
wir noch mal kurz sechs Monate
zurückgehen
ein Journalist ihre Senders hat mich in
New York interviewt und ich war froh
dass ich sagen konnte schaut mal hier
die jungen Frauen die gehen auf die
Straße ich habe ihm sogar gesagt
vielleicht können wir zusammen singen
dass wir wir sollten uns freuen über
diesen Aufstand aber jetzt gehe ich
jeden Abend ins Bett und Weine mein Herz
ist gebrochen denn es sind Kinder die da
getötet werden
Massa Mini war nur 22 Jahre alt sie hat
noch nicht einmal demonstriert aber alle
haben gesagt auch jüngere Kinder die
16-jährige die auch getötet wurde die in
ihrem ihrer Mats eingespielt wurde die
hat gesagt ich bin machsa und andere
Kinder sind gekommen ich bin auch Massa
alle identifizieren sich mit Marsa und
sagen ich bin so stolz weil ich eine
Zukunft sehe in der das Regime nicht
mehr existiert aber diese jungen
Menschen die Kinder sind jetzt
mittlerweile tot
diese Kinder sind nicht nur einfach
irgendwelche Zahlen so und so viel
Menschen sind gestorben
stellen Sie sich das mal vor das wird in
Amerika passieren jetzt ist es im Moment
ganz anders geworden ich bin nicht mehr
stolz sondern ich bin zornig ich bin
wütend das zu wenig dagegen getan wird
junge Leute gehen hin sagen ich bin
machsa und sie werden erschossen das ist
eine ganz andere Situation da gibt es
noch einen Unterschied zur Ukraine zum
Beispiel Präsident selensky hat gesagt
dass das iranische Regime Drohnen
geliefert hat um die Ukraine zu
beschießen also daran sieht man das sind
Kriegsverbrecher und ramini und Putin
das sind Leute aus einer Preisklasse die
sind schlimm und die Welt muss jetzt
endlich gegen die islamische Republik
vorgehen und endlich alles zurück Rücken
genauso wie sie das gegen Putin machen
müssen das ist ganz ganz wichtig
die Ukrainer und die Iraner müssen gegen
Putin und heimenie angehen und wenn wir
das nicht jetzt endlich mit
Entschlossenheit tun dann werden noch
mehr auf der Straße sterben
ja vielen Dank für Ihre eindringlichen
Worte über diese schlimmen Schicksale
bleiben wir da noch mal vielleicht weil
sie sie sagen sie gehen jeden Abend
weinend ins Bett hat sich da jetzt auch
nach dem Tod von Massa Amini diese
jahrelange angestaute wo diese
Verzweiflung die Sie beschrieben haben
entlädt die sich gerade und was könnte
sie verändern
Solidarität
international kann auf jeden Fall helfen
wenn es aber auch zu Taten führt aber
was ich gesagt habe dass ich weine
natürlich viele Millionen von Iranern
weinen aber wir sind nicht nur traurig
wir sind wütend und wir wollen Taten
ergreifen glauben Sie mir das ist nur
der Anfang der Anfang vom Ende dieser
genderappartheit viele sollte sagen ach
das führt sowieso wieder zunächst die
vergleichen das mit den Aufständen
vorher em Iran aber das ist diesmal
anders diesmal ist große Hoffnung da die
jungen Menschen haben große Hoffnung und
die sagen wir haben einfach keine Lust
mehr wir wollen nicht mehr gedemütigt
werden eine von ihnen sagen
dass sie bereit sind zu sterben sie
sterben lieber als sich weiter demütigen
zu lassen das heißt sie gehen auf die
Straße um nicht mehr gedemütigt zu
werden sie wollen nicht mehr unter
dieser Barbarei leben und nicht mehr in
der Islamischen Republik leben die
Frauen und die Leute im Iran können
dieses Regime beenden wenn der restliche
Welt sich solidarisch zeigen und ein
internationalen solidarischen
frauenmarsch einleiten die auf sich
solidarisch erweisen also ergreifen sie
endlich die Taten
das Slogan des Ganzen ist Frau Leben
Freiheit wird dieser Mut dieser Slogan
und auch Aktionen ihrer Bewegung white
weadness der gegründet haben sie
gegründet woraufhin auch mehrere Frauen
im Iran das Kopftuch ablegen werden alle
diese Faktoren was glauben sie aus ihrer
Einschätzung dazu führen dass das
molaregime am Ende zerbricht
ja natürlich glaube ich daran die
Islamische Republik hat alles natürlich
daran gesetzt uns die Hoffnung zu nehmen
aber schauen Sie mal die Islamische
Republik hat zwei Optionen entweder
sagen sie okay
wir haben keine zwangskopftuch mehr und
wir haben auch keine Sittenpolizei mehr
aber
verlangen das die Leute wollen die das
auf der Straße nein es ist nur ein
erster Schritt in die Richtung von
Gleichberechtigung und guter Behandlung
das heißt wenn die Islamische Republik
akzeptiert Kompromisse zu schliefen dann
ist das nicht genug für die iranischen
Frauen sie sagen wenn sie sagen wir
wollen mehr Menschen auf der Straße
umbringen und töten dann führt das nur
zu mehr Wut mehr als 200 Menschen sind
ja schon in einem Monat getötet worden
und ich glaube es sind eigentlich noch
mehr das Regime hat ja schon das
Internet teilweise abgestellt sie wollen
nicht dass der Rest der Welt diese
Brutalität sieht und sie wollen nicht
dass man sieht was da vor sich geht
deswegen müssen wir sicherstellen dass
die Vereinten Nationen das Registrieren
aber gleichzeitig bricht es mir das Herz
dass das iranische Regime bei der
Generalversammlung dabei sein konnten
und da praktisch über Frauenrechte reden
jetzt geht es doch darum dass die
demokratischen Länder sich hinstellen
und sagen das ist jetzt genug ist und
dass die Islamische Republik aus der UN
ausgeschlossen wird viele Millionen
Iranerinnen und Iraner sagen wir wollen
demokratisch sein und wir wollen endlich
das Regime beenden und die Länder die
wählen können auf der richtigen Seite
der Geschichte sollten jetzt aktiv
werden und nicht mehr Milliarden von
Dollars in den Iran schicken
eine Frage kommt noch dazu von einem
User von Falco 2000 bei Youtube er sagt
das Regime hat schon oft solche
Situationen überstanden das Patriarchat
habe das überstanden warum sollten sie
dieses Mal einknicken es seine Frage
oder konkreter was unterscheidet ihrer
Meinung nach diesen Aufstand von
früheren
das ist eine sehr gute Frage
2009 als die Iraner sich auf die Straße
begeben haben hatten sie keinen Kopftuch
das Kopftuch ist die Säule der
religiösen Diktatur das war das erste
Mal tatsächlich das Iraner innen gesagt
haben wir wollen die islamische
Ideologien nicht mehr haben 2009 da
erinnere ich mich das Obama gezögert hat
und wollte die grüne Bewegung nicht
unterstützen aber diesmal sehen wir
das sein das Obama seine Fehler
zugegeben hat und ich hoffe ganz einfach
das Präsident beiden und die anderen
demokratischen westlichen Länder ihre
Lektion gelernt haben sozusagen es ist
nämlich diesmal anders sie sollten sagen
ja wir unterstützen die iranische
Bevölkerung und wenn die nicht
unterstützen dann wird das islamische
Regime wieder die Schuld auf die
westliche Welt schieben und die sagen
das ist sowieso die Schuld der
westlichen Welt wir können da gar nichts
dafür und wir müssen diesmal als
westliche Welt sicherstellen dass das
Regime merkt gut diesmal ist es anders
und dann können wir auch zum richtigen
Punkt kommen nämlich dass die Welt ohne
eine islamische Republik zu haben dann
ist die ganze Welt sicherer nicht nur im
Iran sondern in der ganzen Welt
und eine weitere Frage von Manuel Falke
das geht so ein bisschen in Richtung der
oppositionellen Strukturen in Iran er
fragt was wäre denn die Alternative in
Iran falls es zum Sturz kommen sollte
was wäre aus ihrer Sicht da vorstellbar
was nach dem molarim kommen könnte
erst muss ich mal
sagen erste Mal dass die Opposition in
Iran sich praktisch zusammentut aber man
fragt immer nur nach der politischen
Führung ich muss dazu sagen diese
Revolution wird von Frauen geleitet und
von Iranerinnen im Lande
wir müssen einfach erstmal die Tür
öffnen in eine neue Zukunft und dann ist
es eher so dass es eine intellektuelle
Gesellschaft ist die das Land besser
führen kann als diese schlechten Mullahs
je intellektueller und gebildeter die
Menschen sind desto leichter ist es dann
eine neue politische Führung zu bilden
die Iran in eine bessere Zukunft führen
kann
es liegt jetzt an den Iranerinnen dass
sie eine freie Wahl haben können und
ihre eigenen Führung Kräfte nutzen und
wählen können
wir haben viele gebildete Menschen der
schlechter Archie und chamini müssen
endlich weg
sagt Massi Aline jardt hier bei ZDF
heute live mit klaren Botschaften mit
klaren Einordnungen aber auch
tiefgehenden Emotionen herzlichen Dank
für Ihre Zeit und ihre Einschätzungen zu
den Protestbewegungen in Iran in ihrem
Heimatland danke schön
vielen herzlichen Dank dass ich da sein
durfte
und was Sie Alina sie hat natürlich kam
viele Fragen von euch da im Chat auch zu
ich habe das mal gebündelt zu den
Sanktionen die heute gekommen sind und
auch zu den Möglichkeiten die der Westen
hat und die er jetzt unternehmen musste
hat was sie alle Aline judget uns ganz
klare Forderungen mit auf den Weg
gegeben wir wollen aber bevor wir jetzt
mit Gilda sahibi weiter sprechen noch
einmal auf den Tag der EU-Außenminister
da heute schauen und was sie konkret für
Sanktionen beschlossen haben
15 regierungsnahe Einzelpersonen und
Organisationen werden mit
einreisesperren belegt ihre Vermögen in
der EU eingefroren wir benennen dort
definiert diejenigen die dafür
verantwortlich sind dass Menschen das
insbesondere Frauen die nichts getan
haben als wir Ihre Rechte zu streiten
dass die umgekommen sind das betrifft
Akteure der sogenannten Sittenpolizei
aber es betrifft auch die anderen
Verantwortlichen allerdings wurde heute
auch deutlich dieses Sanktionspaket wird
wohl nicht reichen
ich glaube die allmächtigen in Iran
müssen mal auf den Kalender schauen und
Sie sehen dass wir 2022 sind die
Menschen wollen nicht mehr eingesperrt
sind darum muss die Europäische Union
jetzt diesen ersten Schritt machen ist
das was wir tun können aber ich fürchte
das nicht der letzte man werde die
Situation in Iran beobachten weitere
Sanktionen nicht ausgeschlossen
eine Kollegin Isabel Schäfers war das
vom EU-Außenministerin und Minister
treffen und was dabei schon angeklungen
ist und wer sich da auch in dem Bericht
geäußert hat ist die deutsche
Außenministerin Anna-Lena baerbock und
wir wollen jetzt genau über diese Rolle
Deutschlands und auch die Wirkung dieser
Sanktionen weiter sprechen und das
können wir mit da sehen wir sie schon
Gilde sahibi sie ist Journalistin
hauptsächlich für die taz und auch
Politikwissenschaftlerin schönen guten
Abend Gilla schön dass du bei uns bist
guten Abend
bleiben wir bei den Sanktionen die
beschlossen worden sind da hast du Gilde
auch heute schon zu getwittert das
können wir uns gemeinsam anschauen ich
zitiere dich da einfach mal bei den
Menschenrechtsverletzungen in Iran
unternimmt die EU schreibst du nicht was
den Machthabern weh tun würde nur falls
ich herausstellt dass das Regime
Russland hilft soll es Konsequenzen
geben offener könnte die EU nicht zeigen
dass ihr die iranische Zivilbevölkerung
schnurz ist also Frage an dich dass das
was da heute beschlossen worden ist ist
einfach nur heiße Luft
Sachen dabei die beschlossen wurden und
Sanktionen die auch richtig und wichtig
sind aber ich finde es ist schon
offensichtlich dass es nicht reicht und
es sagen ja also sagt zum Beispiel wir
haben gerade gehört die sagen selber
dass es nicht genug ist und wenn er sagt
wir müssen mal die Entwicklung
beobachten frage ich mich schon auf was
warten Sie denn noch also was soll noch
passieren dass dieses Regime zeigt dass
es brutal ist dass es grausam ist und
dass es Menschen und Kinder und
Jugendliche systematisch umbringt und
dann ist natürlich schon die Frage warum
worauf wartet man warum hat man nicht
gleich die Sanktionen auch entschlossen
und umgesetzt die es auch wirklich
braucht ja absolut berechtigte Frage
dann bleiben wir bei diesem warum und
auch bei der Rolle Deutschlands von
Annalena baerbock haben wir gerade den
Ton gehört du konntest vor wenigen Tagen
gemeinsam mit weiteren Journalistinnen
und Journalisten Annalena baerbock im
Auswärtigen Amt treffen wir haben da
auch ein Foto vielleicht können wir das
ganz kurz zeigen
da sehen wir euch sozusagen im Gespräch
mit Annalena baerbock die Frage die sich
jetzt mir und uns gestellt hat Gilde mit
welchem Gefühl bist du aus diesem
Gespräch dann rausgegangen mit welchem
Gefühl kannst du auch diese warum Frage
für dich weiter einordnen
ich sag mal so ich war jetzt nicht
euphorisch danach also im Prinzip war
das schon was wir dort gehört haben
eigentlich schon das was wir jetzt heute
in der Entscheidung gesehen haben und
mir war und und vielen von uns die das
ganze Geschehen beobachten war
eigentlich klar dass nicht viel mehr
passieren wird als heute passieren
passiert ist und wissen dass also
alleine schon die Tatsache dass es mehr
als vier Wochen nach dem Beginn der
Proteste gedauert hat bis die EU sich
überhaupt dazu berät und sie haben sich
ja nicht mal ein extra dafür getroffen
sondern es war ja Teil der der Themen
die dort besprochen wurden das ist
einfach ein super klares Zeichen das ist
der EU nicht wichtig ist wirklich was zu
tun und dann war heute auch noch die
Aussage auch von Jean hasselborn die
haben ja gesagt
gerade ist es ja wird beobachtet ob das
iranische Regime Drohnen an Russland
liefert mit denen dann die Ukraine
angegriffen wird und da hat Jean sogar
gesagt dass in dem Fall wenn das
bestätigt das ist dann nicht mehr nur
das nur kommt von mir Individuen auf
eine Liste sind die es trifft sondern
dann wird es wohl größer und das sind
eigentlich also da fragt man sich also
wie offen kann man eigentlich damit sein
dass das was im Iran passiert der EU
eigentlich ich sag das übertrieben aber
provokant herzlich egal ist das sind
zumindest die Zeichen die man so liest
also auf jeden Fall auch keine klare und
keine einheitliche Linie und auch ein
langes Zögern diese dieses vermissen
einer einheitlichen Linie das sehen wir
nicht nur auf EU-Ebene das sehen wir
auch in der deutschen Bundesregierung
vor allem bei der Frage rund um das
atomabkommen und um die Verhandlungen
damit Iran ein Beispiel ist auch die SPD
es gibt widersprüchliche Aussagen heute
von Saskia esken und auch von Nils
Schmidt und da hören wir jetzt mal
gemeinsam rein mir geht's aber so eine
aktuelle Situation haben wie wir sie
jetzt im Iran sehen dann ist glaube ich
der Moment gekommen um auch mal deutlich
zu sagen bis hierher nicht weiter aber
so wie gerade im Moment gegen die Frauen
und die Männer auf den Straßen
vorgegangen wird müssen die Gespräche
Enden das hat mit verantwortungsvoller
Außenpolitik nichts zu tun denn ein Iran
mit Atombomben würde Israel unmittelbar
betonen würde die regionale Stabilität
bedrohen noch mehr als das bisher tut
und vor allem wäre auch ein
Rüstungswettlauf zu befürchten
wir sind diese widersprüchlichen
Aussagen zu bewerten
also ich glaube das ist einfach auch
widersprüchliche an also
ja dass die widersprüchliche denken ich
glaube das ist auch okay und das ist
aber schon gut dass es auch kommuniziert
wird nach außen ich glaube halt dass das
Gästen in der in der Konsequenz nicht so
viel zu sagen hat was da passiert ich
nehme an dass die atombehandlung nicht
abgebrochen werden sonst wäre diese
Entscheidung ja auch schon verkündet
worden und bei Nils Schmidt finde ich
also diese Argumentation die man ganz
oft hört man bei dem atomabkommen also
für die Verhandlungen dass das man
Israel beschützen muss finde ich hat
ganz ganz schön viel rutzbar dass man
das sagt weil Israel ist seit Jahren
gegen dieses Abkommen wie es in dieser
Form geschlossen wurde und warum sind
sie dagegen weil sie das erste Opfer
einer ihrer iranischen Atombombe wären
es gibt in Tehran eine Uhr die die Tage
runter zählt wann ist zionistische
Regime zerstört wird und ich glaube da
muss man gerade auch als Bundesregierung
vielleicht doch mehr den Austausch mit
der Isra die Regierung suchen und dort
mit den Menschen mehr sprechen oder mit
den ExpertInnen warum denn angenommen
wird dass diese Atome dass dieses
atomabkommen in der Form in der es
konzipiert wurde und jetzt auch wieder
konzipiert werden soll schwierig ist
also halten wir fest nachdem was du
sagst aber auch Frau Aline jatt vom
Westen so deutlich eure Aussagen muss
mehr kommen mehr Geschlossenheit mehr
Unterstützung und auch eine klare
einheitliche Linie und schärfere
Sanktionen die das Regime empfindlicher
Treffen kommen wir dann von der
politischen Diskussion von den
Sanktionen die wichtig sind die wichtig
sind aber auch noch mal auf die
individuellen und persönlichen
Geschichten rund um den Aufstand in Iran
jeder was beweisen diese jungen Frauen
diese jungen Menschen dort eigentlich
der ganzen Welt in dem sie so mutig auf
diese Straße auf die Straßen gehen
also man muss wirklich sagen dass auch
noch mal wegen wegen dem was der Westen
der Westen tut die Menschen im Iran sind
keine Opfer die protestierende sind
keine Opfer sondern das sind
Kämpferinnen und das sieht man gerade
ganz ganz deutlich und die brauchen auch
nicht die Hilfe des Westens um ihren
Kampf zu führen sie brauchen es aber
auch nicht dass der Westen ihn Knüppel
zwischen die Beine wirft bei dem was sie
gerade machen indem das Regime gestärkt
wird und was sie sehen diese vielen
Bilder die die hatte Massi auch schon
erwähnt von von jungen Mädchen von
Schülerinnen die ihr Kopftuch abnehmen
die den Mittelfinger dem dem
Revolutionsführer zeigen was unerhört
ist wenn man vor allem überlegt wie
indoktriniert diese diese Menschen und
diese jungen Kinder jungen Menschen
aufgewachsen sind dann ist es dann sieht
man eigentlich den Freiheitswillen und
diesen wahnsinnigen diese wahnsinnige
Kraft die da auch dahinter steckt und
auch die Tatsache dass viele junge
Menschen sagen entweder das ändert sich
alles also das Regime stürzt oder wir
wollen nicht mehr leben in diesem System
es gibt für sie für ganz ganz viele
keine Alternative deswegen teile ich das
auch nicht was was der zdf-korresponent
gesagt hat dass das jetzt irgendwie
Reform der Schritt sein also man hört
auf den Straßen von von so vielen
Städten im Iran nicht wir wollen
Reformen und wir wollen irgendwie das
Gesetze sich verändern sondern man hört
tot dem Diktator und wir müssen alle
zusammenstehen sonst zerstückeln Sie uns
und zerreißen Sie uns eine nach dem
anderen also die Menschen die
protestieren aber auch und das ist auch
wichtig viele Menschen die zu Hause
bleiben es gibt ja auch viele Menschen
die sich nicht trauen zu protestieren
weil es inzwischen unfassbar gefährlich
geworden ist zu protestieren auch die
sind gegen dieses Regime die Mehrheit
der Menschen will dieses Regime nicht
mehr und die wollen nicht dass irgendwie
hier ein Gesetz verändert wird und da
ein Gesetz verändert wird weil darauf
haben sie lange genug gewartet
wir können ja auch mal diese
Indoktrination die du angesprochen hast
mal an drei Punkten festmachen du hast
deinen Gastbeitrag für die
Heinrich-Böll-Stiftung verfasst und da
hast du mal aus dem islamischen
Strafgesetzbuch des molaregimes zitiert
ein Zitat einfach das Leben einer Frau
sollte nur noch die Hälfte eines Mannes
wert sein fordern Sie da schreiben sie
als Gesetze nieder oder stirbt eine Frau
bei einem Autounfall erhält ihre Familie
nur die Hälfte der finanziellen
Entschädigung wie die Familie eines
Mannes dritter Punkt Frauen in Iran so
dann das Gesetz Werk benötigen außerdem
die Erlaubnis ihres Mannes um sich
scheiden zu lassen da gibt es überhaupt
eine Erklärung dafür warum religiöse
Fanatiker warum dieses molaregime so
denkt und solche Gesetze verfasst
naja es legitimiert ja auch seine Macht
damit also das diese Gesetze die und die
Zwangsverschleierung waren ja einer der
ersten Maßnahmen die die Rumänien damals
und die das neue Regime eingeführt haben
und diese Unterdrückung der Frau und die
systematischen Einrichtung der Frau ist
wirklich zentral für die ganze für das
Funktionieren dieses ganzen Staates also
sie können jetzt nicht 43 Jahre lang das
gesagt haben dass man für die Reinheit
des Staates der Islamischen Republik
genau das macht was was du auch gerade
vorgelesen hast und jetzt sagen jetzt
ändern wir mal ein bisschen also und die
Beispiele die du vorgelesen hast die
zeigen auch ganz klar dass es keine
Reformen gibt also wenn stellen wir uns
mal vor also ich musste lachen als als
ich gehört habe das Reis hier gesagt hat
wir müssen irgendwie Gesetze verändern
habe ich gesagt habe ich ihr wirklich
gelacht weil ich das ist keine Option
und das ist auch offensichtlich
irgendwie eine Ablenkung stellen wir uns
vor das würde passieren also Frauen
dürften meinetwegen ohne Kopftuch laufen
und sich kleiden wie sie möchten auf den
Straßen glaubt und irgendjemand
ernsthaft dass sie dann all das andere
was du auch gerade vorgelesen hast
irgendwie weitermachen also dass sie
nicht mit mit einem Freund auf der
Straße laufen können Händchen halten
dass sie eben diese ganzen dass sie
komplett entrichtet sind das passt nicht
zusammen also das das Kopftuch ist ja in
Anführungsstrichen nur das Symbol dieser
Dinge die Du gerade vorgelesen hast und
deswegen sind Reformen absolut keine
Option und das würde auch nicht
funktionieren in diesem System also dann
bleibe ich dann noch mal bei dem Punkt
für Dich ein ganz klarer versuch einfach
weiter abzulenken von der Brutalität des
Regimes ja absolut also das gerade in
den letzten
Tagen auch hat man einfach so viele
schreckliche Berichte gehört in audible
hat es sind Sicherheitskräfte in der
Schule reingegangen und haben Mädchen
misshandelt geschlagen und ein Mädchen
ist an ihren Verletzungen gestorben das
sind Sachen die die Menschen im Iran
unglaublich wütend machen es gibt Videos
von Frauen die sich Filmen und sagen ich
bin die Mutter von Gina ich bin die
Mutter von Mika all diese die diese
Solidarisierung und dieses was du den
Kindern antust und was du den Menschen
und den Frauen antust das tust du auch
mir an und das ist in den letzten Tagen
so schrecklich gewesen man hat so viele
Videos gesehen wie Menschen auf der
Straße einfach gejagt werden wie sie
geschlagen werden mit Elektro also
elektroschockschocks bekommen mitten auf
der Straße all das das ist eine
Katastrophe auch für das Regime und es
setzt das Regime unter Druck und
deswegen
versucht es natürlich abzulenken sowohl
für die Menschen im Inland die sich aber
gar nicht darauf einlassen und sich auch
nicht darauf reinfallen als vielen Dank
für das Ausland das auch ganz wichtig
also das iranische Regime hat in den
Tagen vor heute vor dem Außenministerin
treffen haben sie Briefe Versand an die
verschiedenen Länder der EU mit
Drohungen dass sie bloß aufpassen sollen
dass keine Sanktionen umgesetzt werden
und da sieht man es ist dem iranischen
Regime sehr wohl sehr sehr wichtig wie
das Ausland auf den Iran schaut und wie
es reagiert und so ganz klar der Versuch
die Brutalität zu verschleiern die Macht
zu erhalten und narrative zu schüren da
hat sie mal auch eine Frage uns
reingestellt wie kann man es denn
schaffen diese narrative des Regimes
nicht aufzunehmen und wie er es
formuliert nicht darauf hereinzufallen
also jetzt von außen genau
man muss sich halt damit beschäftigen
also das ist auch das was
so schwierig ist in den letzten Wochen
was man in der Berichterstattung ganz
oft sieht weil man man liest Dinge
die teilweise regiepropaganda sind also
wo wirklich eins zu eins teilweise die
Erklärungen des Regimes für bestimmte
Vorfälle genommen werden zum Beispiel in
seidern vor ich glaube drei Wochen jetzt
war das ungefähr da wurde ein
regelrechtes Massaker angerichtet da
haben sich als krester Kräfte aus dem
Hubschrauber geschossen und Menschen
umgebracht das war beim Freitagsgebet
protestieren da auch und da hat
beispielsweise die dpa eigentlich eins
zu eins die Meldung des Regimes
übernommen das sahen Terroristen gewesen
und man hätte sie angreifen müssen und
deswegen ist es glaube ich ganz wichtig
dass man sich klar ist dass man sich
informieren muss dass man nicht
irgendwie nur eine Quelle liest weil in
den letzten Jahren und Jahrzehnten war
die Berichterstattung über Iran
teilweise auch sehr schwierig und es
ändert sich gerade und das ist super
weil sich ganz viele iranische Stimmen
gerade melden und sagen hey das stimmt
so nicht und das stimmt so nicht und da
entsteht auch gerade ganz viel wissen
was vorher nicht da war und ich glaube
sich einfach da informieren
interessieren und nachfragen und
nachschauen das würde ich einfach sagen
das hilft immer aber in dem Fall auch
besonders ja absolut wichtige
Hilfestellung die dann auch
wahrscheinlich die Frage von Hannah Pfau
beantworten wie können dann Medien oder
wir alle es auch vermeiden auf die
Förderer und auch genau auf diese
narrative des Regimes hereinzufallen
diese zwei Fragen kamen dazu dass du die
Hilfestellung geliefert Gilde
abschließende Frage auch an dich zur
kontexturierung wie schätzt du denn die
Chancen ein dass das molaregime durch
die Proteste der Frauen am Ende zum
einknicken oder sogar zum Sturz gebracht
werden kann
also ich glaube dass das Ende des
Regimes begonnen hat wir sehen jetzt was
wir seit vier Wochen seit März vier
Wochen sehen ist etwas was wir noch nie
gesehen haben was ich gerade erwähnt
habe diese Solidarität zwischen den
Menschen zwischen allen ethischen
Ethnien allen Altersgruppen allen
Geschlechtern dass
gemeinsam gefordert wird dass ich das
System grundlegend ändert das haben wir
noch nicht gesehen ich war ein Abend in
Twitter Space Star da treffen sich viele
Iranerinnen und exileraner in und da
habe ich zugehört wie sie ganz
detailliert Anweisungen gegeben haben
wie man Schusswunden und schlagwunden
behandelt wirklich bis zum letzten wie
man die Pinzette halten muss welches
Mittel man nehmen muss und es wurde halt
einfach gesagt und aufgeschrieben und
geteilt damit alle Protestierenden das
Wissen und sich schützen können da ist
gerade ein Grad an an Verbundenheit und
Stärke und Kraft wie wir ihn noch nicht
gesehen haben bisher
und die Freiheit die wir gesehen haben
auf den Straßen wir haben die Bilder
gesehen wie wie Frauen sich das Kopftuch
abreißen Tanzen Singen alles was
verboten ist viele Menschen haben das
jetzt inzwischen gespürt und erlebt und
das ist nicht mehr umkehrbar das wird
nicht mehr umkehrbar sein die Frage ist
natürlich wie lang wird es dauern wird
es Monate dauern Jahre dauern und je
länger es dauert wird es mehr Tote geben
das ist das schreckliche und das
Tragische gerade eine Situation aber
dieses System diese Männerriege die sich
da jetzt als 43 Jahren hält die
irgendwie teilweise Kreise sind die
werden nicht für immer gegen diese
Menschen die Freiheit wollen an regieren
können und das ist was was im Westen
verstanden werden muss wenn es Hoffnung
geben soll auf ein atomwaffenpreis
demokratisches Iran dann sind es diese
Menschen und nicht das Regime und diese
Message muss echt ankommen ein
hoffnungsvoller Appell zum Schluss von
Gilda sahibi Journalistin vorrangig für
die whatsapp für die taz und
Politikwissenschaftlerin herzlichen Dank
für deine Zeit für deine Analysen hier
bei ZDF heute live danke schön
Frau Leben Freiheit mit diesem Slogan
protestieren junge Frauen und junge
Menschen in Iran für ihre Rechte und
gegen das molaregime darüber haben wir
euch heute hier bei ZDF heute live
informiert wir haben versucht einen
Ausblick zu geben vielen Dank dass ihr
mit dem Stream gewesen seid dass ihr uns
Fragen geschickt habt dass wir
Solidarität gezeigt hat habt und ja wir
werden das ganze natürlich weiter im
Blick behalten wir werden darüber weiter
berichten so wie es Gilde auch gesagt
hat und das werdet ihr dann hier wieder
bei uns sehen bei ZDF heute live bis
dahin passt auf Euch auf und macht noch
euch noch einen schönen Abend tschüss